I think homophobia can actually be kind
of dangerous you know a friend of mine
he's kind of a tough guy he went
skydiving recently he's like yeah I'm
not strapping some guy in my back that's
super gay now he's dead
there you go
that's just a weird thing to put your
energy into you know I saw a guy in
Central Park once he was ranting about
gays adopting kids what a weird thing to
be angry about I like seeing a gay
couple to kid you see a gay couple the
kid he knows no way that kid was an
accident right no gay couple could ever
get that [ __ ] up like holy [ __ ] what
happened last night good Lord oh my God
and we rob an orphanage holy moly oh my
God
yeah give gay couple's kids you know we
shouldn't have kids poor people why is
that allowed
terrible idea right
come on my parents are poor I'm a
comedian Red Flag
[Applause]
I don't know
sometimes I wish I was gay you know I
got fired from my last job for sexual
harassment I told a woman she had nice
cleavage they fired me which pissed me
off because my gay friends at work would
get away with murder they're like hey
Shelly how are you honk honk it's like
what why is that okay like well not
attracted to women I was like so what
I'm not attracted to kids I can't go to
a playground hey Timmy oh yeah
foreign
I don't get stuff like that you know I
uh I'm trying to learn but like like
you're a woman wouldn't you rather be
complimented by a group that's into you
I don't care if a lesbian compliments me
nothing gets lesbians but that doesn't
help my ego you know you have a
lesbian's like hey Mark like a haircut
I'm like I know you have the same one